[music]
>> Hello and welcome to to this special
episode of What's Up Prof. Hi Walter.
[snorts]
Hi Martin. Are you doing okay?
Don't ask me.
>> [laughter]
>> Yes, I'm doing fine.
>> We're running around like headless
chickens, but today we've got a very
special guest. Very special guest. Would
you like to introduce him because you've
been working with him for quite a while.
Well, I've known Shahbaz for quite a
long time.
And I'm very happy to be talking to
Shahbaz. He has an amazing testimony.
People should listen to it.
And he is a wealth of knowledge.
And he's very active in his work and
reaching out to the Islamic world. And
it's a privilege to speak to him. Hi
Shahbaz.
>> Welcome Shahbaz.
Hello Walter. Hello brother Martin. Good
to be with you both.
Okay, so
we have also an interesting backdrop
that will be leading into the
discussion. But I think before we
discuss this, let's have a word of
prayer to open up our discussion. Yes.
>> Yes. Okay.
Our heavenly Father, we thank you that
we can be able to do discussions like
these.
It's important, but it's also
not that easy. So we ask that you be
with us with the Holy Spirit and guide
us through this in Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen.
Amen.
This is a very controversial subject
because there are so many opinions and
so many views on this issue.
And I think it's it's a good time to put
some things on the table
to see exactly where we stand on this
issue.
And is it relevant for the time in which
we are living?
So thank you gentlemen for having me. I
this is a privilege to be with you today
and to discuss this very important
subject. Something that is very near and
dear to my heart as I have come out of
Islam myself and converted to to be a
Christian, a Seventh-day Adventist
Christian. And for now,
I don't know for
a few decades.
And I'm thankful to God for for for
bringing me and my family to this
wonderful truth.
Um
I love the people of of the Islamic
world. I I
come from it and my desire is to reach
them with the gospel. And but but
there's been a lot of talk,
denominational talk. And not just in our
church, but in other denominations as
well and and regarding Islam. Is Islam
the same religion as at least is Islam's
God the same God as the God of the
Christians? Is there a similarity
between Christianity and Islam,
specifically between Seventh-day
Adventist Christianity and Islam? And
who is Allah? Is is he the God of the
Bible? Can we trust him?
Does he teach the same teachings that we
read about in the Bible? Um and I don't
want to I don't want to digress nor I
want to move on to something too
quickly, but these are questions that
need to be answered. A lot of people
when I travel in different places
Adventists
come and ask me, "Hey Pastor Shahbaz,
please tell us what do you think about
this teaching that is being taught right
now or what what do you believe about
Allah? Is he the God that we worship?
And so everyone is asking this question
everywhere I go. It it doesn't fail.
Everywhere I go. So this is something
that we should be really opening up
right now and bringing it to people's
attention. So there is a So we're not in
muddy waters anymore, but we have a
clear understanding of what is truth and
and separate truth from error.
Absolutely. That's amazing that you talk
about these things, Shahbaz.
I have of course not been as involved
with Islam as you have because you come
from there.
But I have dealt with
with people in the Islamic religion. And
when I was a professor at the
university,
my students, some of them were Islamic
and there was a large group of Islamic
students at our university.
And I always enjoyed working with them
because they are so serious about their
faith.
And
many of them of course regard
Christianity as rather frivolous
because
you know, there aren't these strict
paradigms that the people uphold.
And they were always amazed because me
also from an Adventist background
was
I was different to the others because I
held to certain standards and norms
which they appreciated.
And also on the issue of creation and
evolution,
they were very much for creation.
And therefore they were often very
supportive of me.
And I found them very sincere and I have
been longing to reach out to them. So I
share that sentiment, but we are going
to compare in our discussion
two issues and two two paradigms and two
documents, the one the Bible, the other
one the Quran.
And
the question is
can they be reconciled? Are they
basically similar stories with a
different angle or are they something
else?
And yes, for that of course
I myself
I haven't always been a Seventh-day
Adventist Christian. I have been an
atheist. I have been an occultist.
I have been a Catholic. I had a I had a
whole series of of
you know, stages in my life.
And when I was searching, I studied
Eastern religions. I studied Hinduism.
And I read the Quran very seriously as I
would read the Bible.
So I am familiar with the Quran and its
writings. And yes, we can have I think a
fruitful discussion on this issue.
Amen.
You know, I
the thing that just
kind of jumps at me is is this notion
that
somehow because Ishmael was Abraham's
son,
therefore because of that relation and
Ishmael's relation to the children of
the East,
specifically
talking about the Arabs, that suddenly
Islam is now a religion that that is
basically fostered
or
or or or presented as a religion that is
divinely mandated. And that's related to
Christianity.
Correct. Yeah, so because of that
Abrahamic connection,
suddenly
there's three groups. There are the
Christians, the Jews and the Muslims.
And they're called the Abrahamic faiths.
And
and this is this is this is a this is an
important question. You know Walter,
when I used to work for Amazing
Discoveries many years ago,
in one of the videos that was produced
on that channel,
an Imam responded to a particular
presentation I did on the question of
who is Allah. And that Imam
agreed with me.
He said he said he said in the comment
section of that channel, he said,
"I I completely agree with the speaker.
The God of Christianity and the God of
Islam are two different gods." Now, he
meant it as evil toward us and good for
him,
but but that was that was and he's
right.
And I am I am of a firm belief that the
gods of Islam and
these are two different gods, completely
two different gods.
We cannot we cannot connect them
together. They just not the same
personality.
Yes. So, if I can
get the ball rolling, I would like to
compare, let's say, the Bible with the
Quran.
Just to get a a basic picture.
Number one, the Bible is a historic
book.
It contains a lot of history.
And that history has been corroborated
by the spade of the archaeologist.
Uh
now, the science of archaeology is a
very young science.
And basically, it really only kicked off
round about 1844
when it was possible to translate some
of the cuneiform writings and uh
decipher the hieroglyphics, etc.
So, the Bible historically has been
attacked in many in many instances, but
it has been corroborated.
And the excavations that are taking
place in the Middle East are just
amazing on that level.
The Quran, on the other hand, is not
really a historic document as I read it.
And some of the history is
different or, let's say,
uh
if compared to the Bible, one or the
other must be out of sync, if I can put
it that way.
Uh to put it mildly.
Then the Bible also is a a book of
salvation.
And the Bible [clears throat] is a book
of prophecy.
And again, the Quran is is a description
of events and a description of Allah and
the relationship between Allah and his
people,
but it is not a prophetic book in the
sense that the Bible is a prophetic book
with very distinct prophecies, very
distinct timelines.
And these prophecies not only affect
kingdoms and powers that would arise on
this earth and those that would play
prominent roles in the his
in the history of humanity,
culminating into in the setting up of
the kingdom of God.
And then the
the Quran and the the Bible differ in
terms of the central figure.
The central figure in the Bible is the
Messiah.
And you read the prophecies of Daniel
and they're all very accurate prophecies
like Daniel chapter 8 and 9 that tell
you exactly the year in which the
Messiah would be born, what his mission
would be.
And then you pick it up in the New
Testament and Christ fulfills every
single one of those prophecies. And they
are exceedingly precise prophecies with
timelines and events.
And
it also talks about the the changeover
from
Israel, literal Israel, to spiritual
Israel. And it all revolves around this
Messiah
who uh in the New Testament is
identified as Jesus Christ.
And
the big problem there for Islam or
compared to Islam is that this this
Messiah is divine.
So,
Jesus Christ is described in the Bible
as the divine Messiah.
And
John makes it quite clear, "In the
beginning was the word and the word was
with God and the word was God." And that
he is the creator, the one who spoke
everything into existence.
Whereas Islam recognizes him only as a
prophet.
And then there are certain powers which
are
portrayed in in the book of Daniel and
in the book of Revelation
that talks about a distorted
Christianity that would be presented to
the world, a false picture which Paul
referred to as a falling away. And that
another power would present itself as a
Christian power.
And the reformers referred to that as
the antichrist, whom they identified
with the papal system. Now, none of that
history is in the Quran. And none of
that timeline or prophecy is in the
Quran.
So, basically, you're dealing with with
people. Jesus is mentioned in the Quran.
Uh
his mother is very prominent in the
Quran.
In fact, his mother is elevated to the
position of the highest woman in heaven
uh in the Quran. So, we have some
parallels and some issues, but Jesus is
only recognized as a prophet.
And there's only one God and that is,
according to the Quran, Allah. And it is
actually an insult to have Jesus
elevated to the position of deity
or even for him to to sacrifice his life
for sins, which is an insult to to Allah
because he needs such no such
machinations
in order to save uh humanity. He can
just do it by decree. So, there are very
distinct differences.
And so, Buzz,
from what I have studied on this issue
is that the Quran is
very similar in its theology or the
attributes of Allah are very similar in
in their theology to what is presented
by the Roman Catholic system.
And therefore, it is a reflection of
Roman Roman Catholicism.
So, in that sense, there is a link
between the so-called Christianity
and the Quran.
But is the God of Catholicism
the same God as that of the Bible?
And here we have a link
because
the people out there want to have the
deities the same, that Allah really is
just another name for the same God that
we have in Christianity. No, he has the
same attributes as the Catholic
portrayal of God.
But it doesn't have the attributes that
are portrayed in the Bible.
And if we can if we can look at some of
the similarities, perhaps that would
make it clearer and you must please give
your comments regarding this.
Number one, the Quran denies the
atonement.
Catholicism denies the atonement.
Catholicism teaches that Christ never
died for you.
He he brought the perfect sacrifice by
obedience, but not for you. You have to
pay your own sins in in Catholicism
because you have to go to a place called
purgatory where you pay for your own
sins. Therefore, Christ in Catholicism
is not the sin bearer.
He's not the one who
takes the penalty of sin,
the wages of sin is death, upon himself.
No, he was just obedient unto death, but
he never took the penalty of sin upon
himself in Catholicism.
And therefore, Islam, when it teaches
that there is no atonement,
that that is a charade, it's the exact
same doctrine as Catholicism.
That's a core doctrine.
When it comes to issues like Mariology,
the Quran elevates Mary above all the
other women in the Quran, even putting
her above Fatima.
And then you have all of these
connections. You have a place called
Fatima in Catholicism where Mary is the
pivotal point.
And I've been to the Middle East where
there are shrines where Islamic pilgrims
come to communicate their wishes to
Mary.
So, this is very similar to what we have
in Catholicism. So, there's no
atonement. And then the other thing is
that Jesus is just a mere prophet in the
Quran
as as Muhammad was a prophet in the
Quran.
And in Catholicism, Jesus is basically a
created being because Catholic teaching
says that he was generated by the
Father.
So that makes him a created being.
So that would put him on the same level
as everybody else and he can be a
prophet, but he cannot be what the Bible
claims that he is.
So as far as I am concerned
the God of Islam
is the same
or let's put it this way, is the God
with the same attributes
[snorts] as that of Catholicism.
But that's not the God of the Bible.
Do you see it like that as well?
Absolutely. I completely agree with you
and and
it's
the similarities between Islam and
Catholicism
they
I'm not talking about what they show on
a weekly basis in Catholic churches.
We're talking about the the underlying
foundational connections between
Catholicism and Islam is undeniable.
It's it's there. You can't you can't
separate the two.
The God of the God of Islam
literally I mean in in the Quran he
denies that he has a son. Yes. And he
even asks Jesus. He says Jesus and it's
interesting
that every time Jesus is mentioned in
the Quran the title follows his the his
name Jesus the son of Mary.
The son of Mary is is all the time
emphasized because the very purpose of
Islam I believe was to not just to be a
barrier against the progress of
Christianity in the Eastern countries
but it was also to
to
take away
Jesus' sonship to the Father in heaven.
And and so that's why
in the Bible Jesus is mentioned as the
son of God in the New Testament and also
in the in the Old Testament at least in
one verse.
And but in the Quran he's always the son
of Mary.
Yes. And and and you're right Mary is
elevated even just
this last month
in Tehran in Iran one of the metro
stations a brand new metro station that
was just opened across the street from
the largest Catholic church in Tehran
there's a metro station dedicated to
Mary. Her image is in the metro station
a beautiful big image and it's one of
the most beautiful metro stations that
you probably have ever visited.
And not far from the Milad Tower in
Tehran there's a there is a there is a
very big statue of Mary that has been
dedicated. Now here is an Islamic nation
that has no problem with with erecting
images to Mary
or even dedicating metro stations and
other things to Mary, but never Jesus.
And
Mary Mary is just looked upon with with
with
not just a regular respect. And
so so in in Islam Mary is is very much
alive. And this is why I believe that
Islam is being used as a a decoy as
well. Let me just say this really
quickly. I believe that Catholicism is
using current events with Islam as a
decoy to get people's attention off of
what the Catholic church is doing and
looking over on the other side while the
Catholic church is is planting and
building and creating its empire and and
bringing the world to that final
takeover that they they're planning to
have. And and they've been they've been
well nice successful anyways they've
already there. And so
it's it's so interesting. I I appreciate
the things you said because I totally
100% agree with you. All right, there's
some core issues that are very important
that people should understand as well.
And one of the the very basic issues
which require a plan of salvation in the
first place
is that the wages of sin is death.
The day that you eat of it says the
scripture to Adam and Eve
is the day that you die.
In other words
death will come in as a consequence.
Now the doctrine of the immortality of
the soul again is a Roman Catholic
doctrine
that has been transferred even to the
other Christian denominations and most
Christian denominations the great
majority of them believe in the
immortality of the soul.
Thus negating that very first statement
in the Bible
that
you are mortal because the Bible says
God alone is immortal immortal and
life is conditional to obedience.
Now if you have immortality then what
happens to those that disobey God they
go to hell
where they suffer eternal torment.
And this has been a central doctrine in
in Catholicism.
And if you are saved you first go to
purgatory to be purged because you have
to bear your
responsibility for your own sin.
And if you go to heaven what is that
heaven going to be like? Well normally
there is a Utopic description
whereas the Bible gives a totally
different picture. It's a place where
you will be in the presence of God yes
but not in some form of Utopia where you
are pampered and receive a lot of ladies
to take care of your needs and all of
these issues. So the doctrine of this
Utopia or eternal damnation in hell is a
Roman Catholic doctrine.
And Islam has the same doctrine.
But the Islamic doctrine on hell is so
descriptive in the Quran
whereas in the Bible you have to you
have to look at types and shadows and
cross references to get the picture of
what it is
what it is about. This hell is the grave
and the other hell is the Gehenna that
fire of cleansing that destroys the
wicked so that they are no more.
Whereas in Islam you are in this place
of burning inferno
where your skin is burnt off and you
receive a new one every day so that you
can feel the suffering and the pain all
over and over again. So it reminds us
almost of Dante's Inferno.
Yeah, right Martin? I just wanted to ask
you now that you mentioned this. That
sounds all of this actually sounds a lot
like mythology like Egyptian mythology
and all these other pagan religions.
>> And and ancient Greek philosophy and all
of these issues.
So that is a totally
synonymous
view as we have it in Catholicism.
And that is not biblical because God is
not a
a monster that will torture you for all
eternity on the basis of one short life
that you've had here on Earth.
And heaven is a place of activity. The
Bible tells that that you will you will
plant and you will you will take care of
a farm gardening planting fruits. You
will build houses. You will you will
communicate with God and be in the city
and it's a life of activity.
Whereas in the Quran you receive a couch
and you lie down and you are served by
individuals and it's a totally different
picture.
But the very basic thing that you
mentioned Shahbaz is Allah doesn't have
a son.
So if he doesn't have a son can he be
the same God as the God of the Bible?
That's the that is the million dollar
question. Really
this question wasn't worth a million
dollars
until some
Christian theologians decided to give it
meaning
because they they started to teach that
Allah is the same God as the God that we
worship as Christians.
And you know in in there's a sura in the
Bible
the sura
and I was mentioning that when when the
when Allah asks Jesus and says Jesus son
of Mary did you
did you teach the Christians that that
you are equal to Allah and that you're
my son? And Jesus says Allah most
beneficent this is a lie that the
heavens tremble at.
So immediately that verse all by itself
sets the Bible completely on some other
place
compared to the Quran.
The Jesus of the of the Quran
cannot be the Jesus of the Bible
because the Jesus of the Bible never
denied his sonship to the father.
But in the Quran, he denies it.
And the the God of the Quran is not the
ancient of days mentioned in Daniel
chapter 7 because the God of the God of
the Quran says he has no son, but the
ancient of days in the in the Bible at
Jesus' baptism, his voice was heard
clearly by everyone that this is my son
in whom I'm
in whom I'm well pleased. And then later
on on the Mount of Transfiguration
before that
later on Jesus also is mentioned again
by the father, this is my son, listen to
him, obey him. So
every Christian has to make this
decision, this confusion that has come
in in the Christian camp
about Islam has to be clarified. Muslims
have no problem
by saying that we and Christians are not
the same.
But we Christians go out of our way to
always claim that we are the same. We
have so much in common.
They have a health message, we have a
health message, they their their God is
the same God that we worship and and
their father was Abraham, our father was
is Abraham and and it's just it's it's
it's all like a confusion, a bedlam of
noise and I think it's time and it's
been I mean I've been working at I've
been doing this ministry for 26 years
and and ever since 2000 I've been trying
to teach this to my brothers and my
sisters that that hey, you know I
haven't made it a mission because my
mission is to save bring people to to
know Jesus Christ. Yes.
>> And but but but on the sidelines as much
as I can I try to make the issues clear
because I'm I'm really tired of seeing
people in our denomination that are just
selling out, completely selling out.
Sometimes they're not selling out
because they want to sell out, but they
are compromising because they either
been deceived or they want to deceive
people.
That's the bottom line. You were you
were mentioning that we have a health
message and I have a health message.
If I can just comment on that a little
bit.
We have a health message, yes, which is
based on what you read in in Leviticus
and in the history of of the Israelites
where God changed their diets and
in the in the walk through
the wilderness for 40 years he he even
tried to get them to to eat a more
healthy diet excluding meat for example
and they rebelled against it and there
were very clear guidelines as to what
kind of flesh foods you were allowed to
eat and those were the clean and unclean
foods
and the list in Leviticus is is quite
exhaustive
and
as a scientist I was very interested
into in this
and basically if you can cut it down to
the basics
the creatures that are unclean are those
that will accumulate more toxins either
because of their lifestyle or because of
accumulation
due to carnivore etc. All carnivorous
animals are declared as unclean for
example
and there are other issues like
coprophagy animals that eat their own
excreta and things like that and the
list is very precise.
When you go to the Quran
that list is
very
restricted.
The pig is declared as an unclean animal
in the Quran but the animals that are
unclean in the Bible like the animals in
the ocean for example, I'm not talking
about fish with fins and scales now, I'm
talking about the other creepy crawlies
like
you know the mollusks and all of those
creatures
they're perfectly fine in in Islam and
these health laws that were
mentioned in the Bible according to
Quran to the Quran were
decreed for the Jews because of their
unbelief and disobedience
not because they were unclean in within
themselves. So in in the Quran
the Muslim is quite happy to eat any of
the marine creatures
and the camel that is declared an
unclean animal in the Bible is is
something that is definitely not unclean
in the Quran. So there are a lot of
contradictions there.
So the health message basically revolves
around
pork
and it
revolves around things like alcohol for
example.
But
one of the the things that are unhealthy
in in the world is for example smoking.
There's no there's no restriction when
it comes to that. So as far as I'm
concerned there is basically no health
message in Islam
other than
pork.
Well yeah,
they in fact in in the Sharia line and
in Islamic tradition a provision has
been made that in times of dearth when
there is no other food even the flesh of
a pig is permissible to be consumed in
Islam. So in times of dearth you can eat
the flesh of a pig in Islam. So there
are there is absolutely no no
correlation, no connection between the
Seventh-day Adventist health message or
the biblical health message and the and
the Quranic as you mentioned. Yes.
They can eat the they can eat the flesh
of camels, they can eat any sea
creatures.
They don't eat lobsters, but they do eat
shrimps. They do eat shellfish,
most most shellfish and stuff.
They they can eat ostrich meat, eggs any
type of birds and stuff they can eat cuz
there is not and and you mentioned
smoking.
Quran doesn't have a Bible verse that
says your body is a temple of the Holy
Spirit. That if you destroy your this
body God will destroy you in in hell.
They don't have that, they don't have
any restrictions except
eating the flesh of
pigs or alcohol and and really the
reasoning behind this prohibition on
alcohol and and the the meat of a pig is
goes back to to the to the Islamic
desire
to reveal or at least show themselves
that they are of an Abrahamic faith.
And because if that wasn't even in if
that was not in the in the Bible today
Muslims would be eating pigs and and
drinking alcohol and all that and that
would have been allowed.
Muslim clerics regularly smoke
cigarettes because there's no
prohibition. They have no belief that
their body is a [clears throat] temple
of the Holy Spirit. Even though the
even though
Quran mentions Holy Spirit
but their understanding of the Holy
Spirit is zero.
Another correlation they make is that
Jesus the the Quran says that Jesus is
Ruh Allah. Ruh which is come is the same
Semitic word as the Ruha in Hebrew which
means spirit or breath.
Allah is the name of the God of Islam.
So in the Quran Jesus is referred to as
Ruh Allah which it means that Jesus is
the Holy Ghost.
And
and you know that there is a teaching
that been permeating in the Seventh-day
Adventist Church for some years now
which is a false teaching that teaches
that Jesus is the spirit of God.
>> Yes. Very good.
>> And but we believe as Protestant
Christians in in in the in the Godhead
Father, Son and Holy Spirit, three
distinct separate personalities
that can exist apart from each other,
but they are one in every aspect. It's
not three in one, they are three as one.
But this teaching in the Quran that
Jesus is Ruh Allah
that he is the Holy Spirit it goes back
to that Catholic
teaching because It's a Catholic
doctrine.
It's a Catholic doctrine.
It's a Catholic doctrine because because
in Catholicism
they teach that Jesus is generated by
the father
and that the father and Jesus once
having been generated together should
have blew breathed the Holy Spirit into
existence. So basically the Holy Spirit
is the spirit of Christ and the spirit
of the father and they are basically one
entity in Catholicism with three
aspects.
But the true Trinity in the Bible is one
in purpose, but three separate entities,
individuals,
powers.
If I may say something here that's
really going to stir something.
The
pioneers of this church,
a lot of them
when you get these arguments, they say
that they were anti-Trinitarian or
non-Trinitarian.
I believe if you do really do your
study, you'll see that they non-Catholic
Trinitarian. Absolutely, and they
weren't Unitarians either. Yes, they did
not go against the biblical explanation
of a triune God. No.
But
and so these people that run
to that side
and say, "Oh, but we the the Adventists
have the same view as the Catholics on
Trinity is
have no clue what the Catholics teach on
Trinity."
>> The irony is, Martin, that they actually
teach Catholic doctrine by making Christ
the generated being and the Holy Spirit
the spirit basically of Jesus Christ.
And therefore they negate
>> And the interesting is
the interesting thing is, Walter and
Martin, that Islam does the same thing.
It's That's amazing. It's It's It's
Catholic teaching.
It's amazing how this just fits in
together. So, if we can just backtrack a
little bit and say, "All right, what
What does the Bible say about end-time
events and who the enemy of God really
is in in the portrayal of the book of
Revelation and the little horn of Daniel
chapter 7?"
Uh
the reformers were absolutely crystal
clear that the little horn represents
the papacy.
The reformers were absolutely crystal
clear that the beast of Revelation 13,
the beast out of the sea, that that
represented Catholicism because it had
the same aspects as the beast or as the
little horn. It persecuted the saints,
it changed times and laws, et cetera, et
cetera.
Now, is Islam
in the book of Revelation has a place,
yes, when it came to
uh you know, the battle between
Christianity and and Islam,
but the role players right until the end
remains the little horn power or the
papal system that ruled for 1,260
days.
Now, suppose
if that is
the Antichrist system that changed the
times and that changed the laws of God
and has a mark which is their mark of
authority which they claim Sunday
worship is their mark of authority.
If that is true and that is the issue in
the Bible,
then Islam is in the same predicament as
the rest of the world, even the
Christian world.
Because when they acknowledge
the papal system
and in their in their fraternity
documents, they are acknowledging them
them each other as brothers and in in
the in in the religion. Isn't it in the
Abrahamic Accord?
>> In the Abrahamic Accord as well,
then
if they embrace
Catholicism
as this leading power
and eventually even may introduce the
mark of authority of of Rome, which is
Sunday keeping, then they run the same
risk as the rest of the Christian world
of being deceived by a power that the
Bible says will have control over the
minds of men in the end of time. So,
mustn't they be warned in the same way
in which the warning of the three
angels' messages has to go to the world?
It doesn't it apply to them as well? I
would love to warn them that they are in
dangerous ground by going into a
alliance in the Abrahamic Accord with
Catholicism and Judaism, both of whom
deny deny the atonement. So, that accord
is three religious systems that deny the
divinity of Christ and the atonement.
And
and the fact that in this in this
accord, which they called Chrislam,
the one world religion complex that's in
Dubai, UAE, um
these there is no
there's no seat for Protestants.
At least for true Protestants, anyways.
Um it's it's headed by the Catholics.
And in fact, all the leaders usually go
to the Vatican. They the Vatican never
goes to them.
And and uh
they have it in UAE because UAE is just
uh it's just uh it was created for the
globalists that that that place. And and
they they in this in this accord,
their entire
premise is to destroy who Jesus, the son
of God, is.
That's the whole premise of this accord
is to to take the world under the guise
of this supposedly peaceful religious
union that they have created. But
really, everyone who has signed that
accord has signed their soul over to the
devil. That's That's the bottom line.
I mean, there's time for them to repent.
Because there's
>> But right now, that's what they've done.
There's no time for Christ in that
equation. Uh only by deception.
>> I remember in your um lecture, Islamic
connection,
you show how all of this goes actually
back to Luciferian
worship.
Both Catholicism and Islam. Because
behind the scenes, you got the exoteric
and the esoteric doctrine that's running
there. So, most Muslims don't know
what's the actual teaching of what's
behind the scenes and where they what
what's the real religion.
>> Yes. You see, false false religion in in
Christianity, and I'm talking about
papal religion, is based on the three
lies of the serpent in the Garden of
Eden.
"You will surely not die." In other
words, the doctrine of immortality.
"You shall be as gods."
And you will be able to distinguish
between good and evil. You don't need
God's law for that. And Rome does
exactly the same thing. They claim
immortality.
They say that Jesus became man so that
man can become like God. That's in their
catechism.
And their basis for moral teaching is
natural law and not the law of God.
Therefore, they can change the law of
God as it pleases them, and they have
done so.
Now, when the Bible says that this power
will set the mindset for humanity, then
I ask myself the question, have they not
done it in
Judaism? Have they not done it in Islam?
Have they not done it in the Christian
world? Because the Christian world today
in its doctrine
is basically Catholic. It has totally
negated the Reformation.
So, the whole world is following the
mindset of the Roman Catholic system.
And the Roman Catholic system has
overshadowed the world to such an extent
that the Muslim is as a captive of their
religion as is the Western world.
Amen. Yeah, absolutely. They They You
know, you mentioned the law, the Ten
Commandments, and and when you read the
Quran cover to cover, when you read the
Hadith, whether it's the Shia Hadith or
the Sunni Hadith,
you you will never find the entirety of
the Ten Commandments anywhere recorded
in their any of their doctrines.
And so, the Ten Commandments is
non-existence in in Islam. Now, there
are
particular sayings in the Quran that
that people have said because I've heard
Christians, even Adventist theologians,
tell me, "Oh, the Ten Commandments is in
the Quran." And
but but it's not. You do not have the
entirety of the Ten Commandments. Now,
you have somewhere it says Allah says
you're not to worship any other gods.
They So, see, that's the Ten
Commandments. But it's not in its
entirety. Or
for instance, the Sabbath commandment is
not even mentioned in the in in the in
the Quran. In the Quran, it says that
talks about the Jews that that the Jews
said that there was there's a Sabbath.
Talks about the Sabbath like that, but
then the Quran brings it right back
around to Jumu'ah or or or the day of
Ummah, the day that Muslims are supposed
to gather, which is Friday. And which
which
So in the Quran, Allah says, "I've given
you Jumu'ah
as your day."
And it's not a full day. It's not like a
Sabbath to them. Muslims go to the
mosque. They leave the mosque. They go
back to their secular jobs. They do
whatever they want to do.
But but there is no placement. So in in
Catholicism, Sunday takes the place of
the Sabbath. In Islam, Friday takes the
place of the Sabbath.
And Sabbath is negated in all these
religions. We're talking about 1.7
billion Muslims.
And and we we talk about another billion
Catholics. They are all negating the
commandments of God. All of it is being
negated. Christ is being negated. His
sonship to the Father is being negated.
His divine purpose, he as the creator is
being negated. I I want to just tell you
something. I had a Muslim one time come
to me. I was doing an evangelistic
seminar in San Jose, California.
For Iranians. And
Iranian Muslim, middle of the seminar,
I think was day 16.
I see this new guy and I went on at the
end of the meetings, I went over to
shake his hand and he got up and said,
"I have not come here to listen to you.
My sole mission is to bring you back to
Islam."
And I said to him, I said
I said, "What's the What is your problem
that I became a Christian?" And he said,
"Christianity is a false religion.
Christianity is a is a corrupt religion.
And and Islam is the only true religion.
Allah is the only true God." And I told
him, I said, "So you have a problem with
Jesus, don't you?" He says he says,
"Yes. Christians teach that he is God."
And I said to him, "I can prove that to
you from scriptures, but I know you
don't accept scriptures." And he said,
"No, I don't accept the Bible at all
except the writings of Moses."
Only the Torah, the first five books of
Moses. And and many many Muslims regard
the writings of Moses as intact. They're
not corrupted, but the rest is
corrupted. I told him, "If I show you
from the writings of Moses that Jesus is
God, will you follow him?" He said,
"It's impossible. It's not there." I
said, "Well, let me show you." So he and
I went to somewhere private and opened
my Bible, took him to Genesis chapter 1
verse 1. In the beginning, Elohim
created the heavens and the earth. And I
explained to him what Elohim means in
the Hebrew
original Hebrew. And and then he said he
said, "Okay, what what does that mean?"
And I took him down to Genesis chapter 1
verse 26 27 when it says, "And God said,
'Let us make man in our image. Let us
make him in our likeness. In the
likeness of God he God created them. He
created them male and female.'" And then
I said, "Who's this us speaking here?"
He said, "I don't know." I said, "This
has nothing to do because in the in the
Quran
Allah refers to himself as
us, we.
He's not talking about polarity
multiplicity here. He's talking about in
the Arabic religion in the in the in the
formal format of the Arabic religion, if
I was to speak to you, Walter or Martin,
I wouldn't use the word you singular. I
would use the It's like in French, the
word vous, which is plural.
Because I'm trying to respect you. They
do that to monarchy as well. They do it
in Persian, in Arabic, in French, in
many languages it's built that way.
That's why Quran was written that way.
And I told him, "Bible was not written
that way." And he said, "So who's
talking here?" I asked him, "Do you
think it's the angels?" And he thought
about it. He says, "Well, I don't think
angels can create." I said, "No. He's
talking to someone." So I took him Let's
go to Genesis chapter 11, took him to
where God said God came and he
confounded the languages. He divided the
languages. Let us Let us confound their
languages. And then he said and then and
then I took him to John chapter Now I
could take him to New Testament because
I built his confidence
from the writings of Moses. Took him to
New Testament John chapter 1 verse 1.
And
and it says, "In the beginning was the
word and the word was
with God and the word was God and
everything was made by the word." And
the word in verse 14 became flesh.
The minute he heard all of this,
I tell you, he tiptoed backwards. He hit
the wall behind him. And then he said,
"Maybe I need to become a Christian."
And he ran to his car. He turned that
engine on. He revved that engine. He
took off. He never came back. Never saw
him again. But I pray that he has become
a Christian since. So the point is this
is that Muslims argue that the Bible is
corrupt.
And my my response to them has always
been, "If you believe that the Bible is
corrupted and you believe that its
origins were good, that that you say
Allah gave the Bible,
but the Bible was corrupted,
so Allah
was forced to bring the Quran.
What guarantee do I have that that same
Allah that failed the first time from
protecting his own word
will not fail again?"
And and and no Muslim can ever answer
that question.
It's a very good question.
>> that question.
What was that? I said that's a very good
point. If you if you had to go
uh deeper into the Torah
and show him the plan of salvation in
the sanctuary system,
that is all about Jesus.
And when when Moses speaks about a
prophet like him that would come,
they relate it to Muhammad.
But
the prophecies related to Jesus Christ
because they even give the timelines
exactly in in the Bible. So yes, that
that is the story. Now, I have a very
similar story. Well, not a similar
story, but a story.
Uh I had a visit from an Islamic lady
from Saudi Arabia.
And she came to my house.
And she wanted to consult with me and
she was a strict Muslim.
But she had a problem with the position
of women within the Quran and the
position of women in the future life,
the hereafter.
And she she was basically saddened by
this doctrine
that
the woman is basically there to serve
basically the needs of the man.
Whereas in the Bible, of course,
Adam and Eve were co-equals. She was
placed by his side, not under his feet.
So she came to me and she asked me,
"I must in in one sentence tell her what
the difference is between uh
Christianity and Islam."
And I I said
the difference is, "For God so loved the
world that he gave his only begotten son
that whosoever should believe in him
should not perish, but have eternal
life."
And she said no, she can't accept that
because she doesn't accept the deity of
Christ.
And or the sonship of Christ. And so I
did the same thing you did. I gave her a
Bible study.
And when I done the Bible study, she
said,
uh now she's totally shocked because
then Jesus is is who he claims to be,
then he's God, because it's in the
Bible. And I I did very similar thing to
what you did. And then she said to me,
"What are the attributes of these this
God and what is the position of the
woman?"
Now, if you read the Quran, it's very
very clear
that a woman doesn't reach the same
stature as a man. For example, if you're
in a court case,
there have to be two women for each one
man. Also in the in inheritance and all
of these issues, the woman takes a very
secondary role.
And I explained to her the co-equality,
but that there is a hierarchy.
But that it's based on love and respect
for each other on the same level.
And she burst into tears.
And she says, "But I want that God."
"I want that God."
And I said to her, "But you can have
that God." And she says, "But if I go
back to my country and I show that I
have this God, they will kill me."
And I said, "Well,
I understand your predicament, but
I don't know what to tell you on that
issue other than that you can keep it in
your heart."
And so
she actually knelt down with me and we
prayed.
And then she left and I don't know what
happened to her thereafter.
But there is this terrible longing for a
God that loves you, that wants to take
care of you, that's prepared to even die
for you, rather than this
separated [snorts] God who looks at you
and sees whether you come up to scratch
or not, and on the basis of an arbitrary
choice takes you to heaven or condemns
you to eternal hell.
Amen. Praise Praise be to God. I am
confident that she is following her
savior today. And the seed was planted.
This is This is beautiful beautiful
testimony. My heart just My heart is
longing to see every Muslim become a
believer of Christ and follow him. I
have some I I wanted to give you some
good news um in the country that I
represent. I'm originally I'm from Iran.
And um
and and in Iran, according to GAMAAN,
which is a institution in the
Netherlands, and they do statistics and
and they collect data. They did a
research on Iran. It took them like I
think 3 or 4 years to gather all the
data. And they concluded This is about 3
years ago, maybe 4 years ago this came
out,
um that that Iran has the fastest
growing Christian church in the world.
The church in Iran is growing at a rate
of
literally almost 20% annually.
And um and and and this the statistics
said that 60% of Iranians have already
left Islam in their hearts. They are not
Muslims anymore. And
and and many have become
either Zoroastrians,
many have become atheists,
and many many more have become
Christians. And 40% of Iranians still
consider themselves as Muslim as of 5
year 4 5 years ago. Out of that 40% only
2% practice Islam on a daily basis. The
other 38% do not go to the mosque. In
fact, in Iran, mosques are closing at a
rate that is unbelievable. And by one
news commentator it said that in one of
these popular news uh medias channels,
he said Iran is the first post-Islamic
nation the world has ever seen.
Um
Muslims are looking not just in Iran, in
in Egypt, in Saudi Arabia, many
countries in the region, people are
turning to Christ. Angels are visiting
people. People are having visions and
dreams. And they're seeing the truth and
they are they are converting. And um and
and our job our ministry is to reach
them and to tell them and to help them
to understand so that in this transition
they can they know where they're
supposed to go. Where is Where is their
support
system? Obviously, Jesus is their
support first and foremost. But where
the church
exists, they can turn to that church.
And and right now in Iran we have many
many many underground churches
uh Adventist underground churches uh
that are are every Sabbath they're
worshipping and they're honoring Christ
and they are they are they are growing.
Uh this ministry is growing leaps and
bounds and God is working in a mighty
ways. We're going to see a lot of
Muslims come to Christ very soon. But I
wanted to point to one thing Walter and
Martin. And that was that's in in in
Genesis because the everybody talks
about
there's a well-known author in the
Seventh-day Adventist Church. He wrote a
book called Islam God's forgotten
blessing.
And his premise is is that Islam is a
blessing that has been forgotten. And
he's he's using the the the couple of
times that the Muslim
forces
basically attacked Europe and
because of that the the the the the
Reformation movement was saved. Remember
the the
the they the the soldiers the
that the Catholic military the Catholic
soldiers that were attacking the
reformers, then the there would be a
loud cry that the Muslims are attacking
our southern borders. So they would
retreat and go back and to defend the
borders. And couple of three times even
the caliphate admitted, "Hey,
I'm I'm I'm God is using me to save uh
the the Protestants."
The thing is is
they use these these these arguments to
prove that Islam is a blessing. But wait
a minute. I thought that Cyrus and the
Persians who did not worship the true
God of Israel, they also saved Israel
from their Babylonian captivity. But God
never said that the that the Jews are
supposed to become Zoroastrians now
or or or worship Mithra.
But you know,
God God is sovereign. He can use even
his enemies for his purpose. He does He
doesn't He does it all the time.
What's that? I said he does that all the
time. All the time. And and the verse
that I want to mention is in is in
Genesis chapter 16 verse 12 where the
angel of the Lord meets with Hagar and
and tells Hagar in in chapter 16 verse 7
through 14, he's talking to Hagar and he
says to Hagar, "Where are you going?"
"I'm fleeing from my mistress Sarai."
And and the angel says, "You have to go
back to your mistress. You You know, you
have a son. His name shall be called
Ishmael." So okay. Unique because now
God is actually giving the name of the
son of this Egyptian bondwoman. Well,
not a bondwoman, but she was a
Sarah was her mistress. Uh
and
she and then the angel says,
"He [snorts] will be a wild man. His
hand will be against
all men and all men's hand will be
against him." The word wild man there is
translated from the original Hebrew
which it says wild donkey.
He will be a wild donkey kicking. You
can't tame him.
He's He's just going to be a wild
kicking donkey. His hand will be against
everyone and everyone will be against
him.
Basically Basically, there there is a
prophecy of Islam right there through
Ishmael and his connection with the with
the Arabs. And and
and In fact, he didn't even even even
move. He He went to the wilderness of
Paran and it was his children that mixed
with the Arabs.
And the and his wife was an Egyptian
wife that his mother picked for him from
Egypt because his mother is Egyptian.
Ishmael is 3/4
He's only He's only
children's His children are 3/4
Egyptian.
He's only half Semitic from his father
and half Egyptian North African. I'm not
arguing that that that that is Muslims
are not Ishmaelites. But what I'm saying
not all Arabs are Ishmaelites and not
all Ishmaelites are Arabs. And and so So
the fact that the Bible predicts there's
a prophecy about Islam that will be a
wild religion. It will be always
fighting everyone and everybody will be
fighting it. We're seeing that on the
news every day.
It's happening all the time.
Well, there's a greater connection also
via Esau.
Because Esau also intermarried with
Ishmaelites.
So there is that connection and it's
interesting
that Petra, for example, was a very big
religious center and Mecca is a much
later construct and happens to be on a
on a pagan lay line
uh of religious systems. So there's a
whole issue there as well.
God wants to save all nations because
the gospel is for every tribe and people
and nation.
And there will be seed of Abraham even
through the line of Ishmael that will
accept Jesus. And there are web pages
now that tell about all of these
miraculous dreams that people are having
that Jesus is uh the true Messiah, that
he will come again.
But there's another aspect about the
Bible and Quran that's interesting. And
that is the question of free choice.
Uh
in the Bible, you have angelic beings
that are described and you have humanity
that's being described. So there are two
orders of being. In the Quran, there are
three orders of being.
You have You have the angels, then you
have the genii, and then you have
humanity.
And uh when in the Quran,
Allah told
uh the genii that they must bow down to
humanity
and be subjugated to them, they refused.
And uh
So they have a freedom of choice. But
according to the Quran, the angelic host
doesn't have a freedom of choice.
And humanity has a freedom of choice.
And they have this intermingling this
confusion of the genii with Iblis, the
leader of the genii. And in the Quran,
these entities actually were
instrumental in building the temple
in Jerusalem.
So that wasn't something that Solomon
did, but that genii actually helped to
construct. So you have
you have basically demonic entities uh
involved in in building of the temple.
So, there's a total confusion as to that
part of their religion as well.
And uh yes, is it like that or is it
not? Are there good genie eye like you
see in the movies when the genie comes
out of the bottle and bad genie eye that
will, you know, try to deceive you? But,
basically, according to the Quran, a
Muslim cannot be received deceived. Only
the Christian can be deceived.
Now, I I had this question when I did
Islamic connection
whether Rome, that was supposed to rule
from 538 to 1798,
and Islam arrives after 538,
whether [clears throat]
in the secret echelons of the
underground currents of secret
societies,
whether there wasn't some concord
between them and Islam might have been
used to get rid of true Sabbath-keeping
Christianity
in the Eastern churches, so that Rome
would be able to rule because the
Islamic religion is the same as
Catholicism, as we have discussed.
They even use beads for praying.
They've got the same
um emblems and stuff on the churches.
>> have the the moon and
the star in it, which is the Roman
Catholic monstrance with the host in it.
It's basically
uh a relic of Baal worship.
So, you have all of these issues. So, is
that not plausible?
And why why do the secret societies like
uh the Shriners, for example,
wear a fez with the Islamic symbols on
it, plus the Islamic sword that was uh
used to destroy Christianity,
and by chopping off the head, which is a
feature of ISIS, for example,
and uh why do these secret societies and
these Freemasons honor
Islam and the fez, which was a symbol of
the blood shed by the Christians in uh
the river fez?
So,
we know that
uh that the higher mes- Masonic echelons
are Luciferian.
So, obviously, they must have the same
doctrine as the Luciferians. And they
put the Quran and the Bible on the same
level
because they teach the same doctrine as
interpreted by Catholicism and Islam,
and not really the Bible.
I've got two questions. The one is
the mark of the beast.
How will Islam accept the
What are they going to do? How is that
going to be work working to try and
implement this mark of the beast? And
then you've been talking about the
Sabbath.
Um They I've heard
uh um preachers in our denomination say
that the reason why we can have
similarities by Allah and God is because
the root word for God is actually more
pagan than the word Allah is for God.
Is that true?
Can we just get to know
Can you just explain to on those two
questions?
What's your take? That is so sad. Now,
um
the English word If they're talking
about the English word God, obviously,
the English word God is is just a
neutral word in English language, which
has evolved.
And and it represents any deity in any
religion, obviously. So, there's a
You can argue that, but that's not a
strong argument. That's not That's not
theology. That's not That's not taking
taking a word in pieces. Allah Allah
predates Islam, the word the name Allah.
And the name Allah has a has an address,
has a direction. You know, when you say
Buddha,
everybody knows what you're talking
about. When you say Allah, everyone
knows what you're talking about. Um
uh
Allah Muhammad the prophet of Islam, his
father's name was Abdallah,
which means in That's an Arabic word,
which means the servant of Allah.
And and obviously, his father was either
named Abdallah or he actually was a
priest
that served
Allah. Pre-Islamic
uh Allah in in in in Arabia. That means
that Allah was already worshipped by
Arabs before Islam even became a
religion in that region. So, it was a
pagan. You can't have the You can't have
the cart before the horse. Muhammad's
father was born before Muhammad. At his
birth, they named him Abdallah. And um
and when Muhammad
comes on the scene,
uh
and I know now there are historians that
even challenge whether or not he even
existed.
And even Mecca didn't exist. But, when
he comes on the scene in in Mecca
uh or Mecca or however you pronounce it
in he comes and there's this there's
this square building called Kaaba. And
and Arabs at that time worshipped 300
deities. And the the number one deity
they worshipped was Allah.
It was a black stone
that that they It was actually a meteor
that had come down from from the sky and
from space. And this they found this
meteor and it's a it's a it's very it's
metallic and it's black.
And they they put it in Kaaba and they
said this is the god that came down and
from moon. And they worshipped it.
Muhammad comes on the scene. He gets rid
of 299 of those idols.
And he takes that last one and he says
this is not Allah.
This is the eye of Allah. That's why in
Kaaba, if you look in Kaaba, if you go
look through research that black stone
is encased in a golden eye, shape of an
eye, and it's in Kaaba, and every Muslim
faithful Muslim goes to to to the
pilgrimage, and they go around the Kaaba
seven times
worshipping that stone. And and so so
Allah predates Islam. Allah And some
people even argue, well,
Elohim is a form of Allah. Absolutely
not. This is This is This is nonsense.
Everybody is so desperate to to make an
ecumenical mess out of our divided world
that that that we're willing to just
negate
every immoral differences just for the
sake of unity. Mhm. But, there can't be
unity when there is truth is being
compromised. Amen.
>> And and this is this is the problem that
we're having even now in our church
>> Yes. to to a great degree. And and and
I'm not condemning the Seventh-day
Adventist Church. I love the Seventh-day
Adventist Church. All of us are serving
God's church and and and we will
continue to serve the church. But, we
are having problems and we got to call
it
call call it out. This is my take on it.
I would love to hear what you gentlemen
think. I think exactly the same thing.
And I've had
uh higher officials within our ranks
come to me and say
that uh Islam the Muslim doesn't have to
come out of his system because the only
difference is a cultural system.
He can stay in his mosque. He can stay
in his worship system.
Uh I used to be a Roman Catholic. I had
to come out of the system. I cannot be
part of Roman Catholicism, which is the
beast of Revelation,
and has the dragon
>> [clears throat]
>> giving him his power and his seat and
great authority. I cannot stay within
that system. I have to come out and be
separate. The same applies to Islam.
Now, you mentioned the eye, and the eye
is so important. Now, just jump to
Catholicism. How important is the
all-seeing eye in Catholicism?
It's important right from the very
beginning. You have it in many many
cases, and then, of course, it's
perfected in Jesuitism.
In every Jesuit conclave, there is the
all-seeing eye. And why should that very
same symbol be the same symbol that you
find in Masonry, Mhm. which is basically
uh Luciferian worship, and you find it
in the occult world.
Uh you find it all over.
And
all of these these things point to one
basic form of worship, which is
Luciferian.
Now, if if that the true deity that is
served by these entities is Lucifer,
and I cannot see it any other way
because they believe his doctrine,
and they follow the lies of the serpent
from the Garden of Eden and and
immortalize them in their doctrines,
then they must be Luciferian at heart.
And that is a esoteric doctrine, which
the initiates would know about.
And there is an exoteric doctrine that
the uninitiated is kept in slavery to.
And I believe exactly the same that
happened in Catholicism is happening in
Islam. And these poor people have to go
through rituals, they have to have their
their prayer times in specific places.
If you follow the ritual, then you're
fine. Catholicism does the same thing.
If you pray your rosary, if you go to
the mass, if you do your pilgrimages,
then you get points. And you get
absolutions from purgatory, the same
with Islam. You have to do a pilgrimage.
It's a It's a religion of works.
It is not the religion of the Bible. And
therefore, these brethren of ours that
ask for the blessing of Islam Allah, for
example,
are inadvertently, in my opinion,
practicing
what the occult world is practicing and
what Catholicism is practicing.
It's a very dangerous precedent. There
are only two systems.
And the one is based on the Messiah,
faith in the Messiah, and obedience to
his precepts.
Everybody who deviates from obedience to
his precepts and acceptance of his
atoning sacrifice is in a false
religion,
no matter what we're going to call it.
Yeah, absolutely. Absolutely. You know,
there there is uh
uh
there is this um you talked about the
genie I in in uh
in the Quran that you read about and and
when I was a kid, I remember we were
always scared, you know, that the genie
I will come and get you and all that and
and
and you never thought about fallen
angels or angels. Angels were kind of
like dismissed.
Genie eyes were the ones that were uh
the the the the boogeyman and that you
were had to be scared of and stuff. And
uh the the devil had has worked really
hard to get the attention off of
himself, hide himself,
and create this scary situation to
control people through fear. And and all
these false religions control people
through fear. And that's what
Catholicism does as well. Controls
people through fear. If you don't obey,
you're going to burn in hell, you're
going to be in purgatory for so long,
and then you're going to be this, and
then you're going to be that, and and um
and I remember when I first became a uh
Seventh-day Adventist, just shortly
before I became a Seventh-day Adventist,
I remember I was praying to Allah, and I
was literally beating my body trying to
appease Allah to get him to listen to
me. And that's when he didn't listen to
me, and that's when I fell to the floor
and I was crying and and I I didn't say
Allah anymore. I used the word God.
This is proof This is a case in point.
Um in my case, in my experience, when I
met Jesus, I was literally calling
Allah, and nothing happened. And I was
crying, I was weeping, I was beating my
body. I wanted forgiveness. I needed to
be forgiven. I was 18 years old. And
during during that that that traumatic
experience I was having, at the end of
it,
I just gave up. I fell to the floor. I
was weeping weeping like a baby. And I
cried the last words that I said.
These were the final words I was saying,
and I was giving up. And I said, I
didn't say Allah anymore. I used the
word God, which is neutral.
The word God is neutral, obviously. And
I said, God, please help me. The minute
I said that, Jesus showed up in my room.
He actually appeared in the middle of my
room.
Now, I'm praying for 40 minutes, Allah
Allah Allah, beating myself, crying, and
asking for help. Nothing happens.
But he couldn't come. Had Jesus showed
up when I said Allah,
he would have one denied himself,
and two, I would have remained a Muslim.
I would have never become a Christian.
And and but Jesus showed up as Jesus,
not as Allah,
and changed my life. My life changed,
and I became a believer. And and so did
all my family members eventually, one by
one. And they met Jesus in their dreams
as well. So So So yes, this question
about Allah is clear. Uh
even a Muslim Imam agreed with me,
although he took it as a point for
himself.
Uh but but you know, fi- the final thing
that that that really stands out in in
this discussion, also, just equally, is
eschatology.
The eschatological
views of Islam regarding what happens at
the end of uh time, when everything
ends, and judgment has come and all
that. And And And there are so many
people in the church that that cry and
say, "Oh,
uh we are all the same with the Muslims.
They have eschatology, we have one.
Jesus comes, there you know, they say
Jesus will come and all that." And And
the question is, is it really the same?
Is our eschatology and their eschatology
the same? Are they teaching the same? In
fact, do they even have
a theology that we can actually rest on
and and and look at it as a solid um um
solid way of theologically
understanding, line upon line, here a
little, there a little, as as Walter
mentioned earlier in the program, Quran
uh
uh is it you don't find many things in
the Quran. In fact, the Quran was
written in a very confusing way.
There is no line of reasoning. And and
there's there's is is is is
disorganized.
There is no uh there is no theology in
it. There is no line upon line here li-
line upon line, here a little, there a
little, that you can compare verses and
and come out with a theology. There is
no
two or three witnesses, if they agree,
so it's established
uh
way that we as as Christians study the
Bible. So, these are the things that we
need to talk about. I would like to hear
what what you have to say about the
eschatology of of of the Quran and and
the Bible, and the second supposedly the
second coming of of uh when Mahdi will
come back the at the end, and and Jesus
supposed to be coming right behind him.
And and and the end will come. Okay,
let's look at these two aspects about uh
the eschatology and and the Bible and
the Quran as a book.
Let's first look at the the Quran and
the Bible as a book.
Catholicism does not accept the Bible as
nominative
only in the sense as it is in harmony
with their tradition.
So, tradition is above the Bible in
uh Catholicism.
In true religion, the Bible is above
your tradition. You have to come into
harmony with your tradition.
In the Quran, as you say, there are many
confusing things, and I I believe the
Quran also confuses Mary with uh the
sister of Moses rather than the mother
of Jesus at a much later stage. So,
there are many confusing things there in
in the Quran.
Uh the Quran's value in Islamic life is
basically in song.
There is a divine reading of the Quran,
which is done, and the method of reading
it, rather than the content of what you
are reading, is important. The way you
pronounce it, the way you sing it,
et cetera. Now, in Catholicism, you have
the same. In Catholicism, you have what
you call lectio divina, divine reading,
where the Psalms and the verses in the
Bible are sung in a particular chanting
fashion.
That's a correlation with Islam. It's
exactly the same thing.
And there would be a a singer and a
reciprocity
a response. And you have the same also
in Islam.
So, it is totally the same as
Catholicism, and Catholicism is a pagan
religion. It's not Christianity.
So, that's the one point. When it comes
to eschatology,
many in Islam long for the coming of
Jesus
because Jesus in the Quran denies anyone
or will punish anyone that has deified
him.
So, in in
um Islam, the coming of Christ is a
retributive action. He comes to punish
those that worshipped him as deity.
Whereas in the Bible, he comes to
uh gather those that worshipped him as
deity. So, it's the exact opposite.
So, the eschatology is the destruction
of Christianity and the survival of
Islam.
Whereas in the Bible, it is all that
come into harmony with God and keep his
commandments and accept the atoning
sacrifice of Jesus Christ are embraced
in the kingdom of God. It's a universal
message of salvation and not the
destruction of one in favor of the
other.
Beautiful. Praise God. That's absolutely
correct. Absolutely right. And And this
is the whole purpose of Islam to take
away the the deity of Christ. You know,
five times a day when the call to prayer
is done at the minarets in all the
mosques around the world, Sunni
religion, and in the Shia religion it's
done three times a day.
Part of that
Part of that call to prayer is the
denouncing of anyone that claims to be
equal to Allah. That Allah has no
consort.
So, five times a day they proclaim from
the minarets. The whole The whole
purpose and existence of Islam was to
deny the deity of Christ. That's the
whole purpose of Islam is to that and
also create a barrier
against the the the the growth of of
Protestant Christianity in the East. And
And it became a wall. You know, another
interesting thing about the eschatology
of Islam is is the teaching that they
believe that when Mahdi will come,
Christ will come after him. And then
Christ's whole purpose is to to fulfill
whatever Mahdi says. And And obviously
one The most important thing is to to
destroy those who deified him. But But
he also will kill 70,000 Jews only.
70,000 Jews. And he will proceed to kill
all pigs on earth. Every four-legged
animal creature we call pig
will be killed.
All hogs, pigs, boars, all of them.
Jesus will kill all of them. His job is
finished.
He will He His job is finished. Jesus
will get married, have children, and die
after 40 years.
But Mahdi will live forever.
And And And And And I asked I asked
those in in our group in our
denomination that teach that we have a
similar eschatology as they do. Where do
you see the similarity? How can you
connect these dots that don't even
exist? Now, in in the esoteric world and
in some denominations that call
themselves Christian that are not
Christian,
there are these two sons of God. The one
is Jesus and the other one is Lucifer.
And they believe that Lucifer was the
the elder one, the true son of God, and
Jesus was the usurper, and that Lucifer
will take his throne back.
Now, there are even denominations that
call themselves Christian that believe
that. Let's not go into into that
detail, but that is what the esoteric
world believes and therefore they
worship Lucifer as the ultimate winner.
Now, as you have just explained, this
Imam Mahdi who will come
uh and Jesus will follow him,
isn't that the depiction of the same
thing where Lucifer, the true son of
God according to them, is the one that
lives forever and the other one
is denigrated to humanity and will die
and disappear off the stage of history.
So,
all of these religions out there are a
negation of Christ.
>> Yeah. Bringing him lower. And the most
deceptive one is Catholicism.
And that what makes it the the son of
perdition, the denier, the betrayer of
Jesus Christ. You know, this word
uh son of perdition
is used only for Judas
and for the man of sin.
They pretend to worship Jesus,
whereas they deflect the worship to Mary
and other entities like the saints that
are all deceased. They deny the
divinity,
the true self-sustaining
divinity of Christ and make him a
created being and present that to the
Christian world as though they were
Christians. They're not.
They are the enemies of Christ. They are
Luciferian in their worship.
I had a a a man who grew up in in a mom
family
who told me that he once overheard uh
group of imams in his family
worshipping a secret form of Allah which
was basically occult
behind the scenes. And uh
because he overheard it, he had to take
part in that ritual eventually and
become initiated.
So, again, you have, it seems to me from
that story and it's a very credible
source,
uh that you also have an esoteric and an
exoteric portrayal of the religion
uh for the insiders and the outsiders.
Of course, Masonry is very prominent in
Islam as well and you have all the
Islamic lodges.
And behind the scenes, they are actually
one in worship,
but externally
they are not. So,
this is very fascinating to me. There's
only one true religion and as far as I
can understand it, corroborated
not only through faith, but through
actual historic data and prophetic data.
And you will only find that in the
Bible. You will find it in no other
writing.
Amen. Amen. Amen. Praise God. I
I am so blessed to spend this time with
you gentlemen and and
just a wonderful wonderful wonderful and
and and I wanted to say that that um in
our mission to reach people, whether
they are Catholic or Muslims or
Protestants or Buddhists or Hindus or
whatever they may be,
that that truth will prevail. Truth
always prevails. And And error has has
no place.
Cannot even stand in the presence of
truth. Now, people may hold on to error
and think that error is is going to be
victorious. People ask me, "How do you
minister to a Muslim?" And I tell them,
"Read them from the Bible." The God has
promised that if you if you cast your
bread, it will return to you.
The word of God will not return to me
that Jesus says void. So, his word will
not return to him void. And And And
people are scared of sharing the Bible
with Muslims. And I tell them, "No, just
like you did, Walter, with that Arab
woman from Saudi Arabia, you study the
Bible with her."
Yes. What else can you do? The word of
God is the only truth that we can rest
our faith upon. And it is a living word
of God and it has power. Every time I
open the Bible, I hear noises, not not
psychologically, but spiritually. I hear
I hear the noises of beasts and I see
nations and I see the future and I see
the past and I see history. I see the
truth of God. I see the cross of Jesus.
I see the agonizing of the son of God. I
see his victory over sin, over death,
and I see that I can have life and have
it more abundantly through Jesus Christ.
And when I share this word with anyone,
whether they're Muslim or not, it will
not return to God void. Somewhere there
will be a response. They may say, "No."
That within itself is a response.
But it will accomplish that which God
has said for it to be to do. And it this
word will accomplish. Let's not be
ashamed about the word of God and hide
it. Let's share it, whether it's a
Muslim or not. And don't don't worry
about whether or not they believe that
the Bible is is corrupt or not. Just you
read it because your faith in the Bible
is contagious. When you believe the
Bible with all your heart, with all your
mind, with all your soul, with all your
life,
no one can deny you.
No one can deny you. You know, when
>> Sorry, I get emotional, but that's my
love. Perfect. It's wonderful. The day
The day you said, "God, Mhm. help me."
That's when you got your answer.
I sat in a in a Catholic church and I
said,
"If you exist, God, reveal yourself to
me." Where did he take me? He took me to
the Bible. Mhm. And I came out of that
system in the same way a Muslim must
come out of that system because he's
been deceived.
And he must accept the truth as it is in
the scriptures.
That system is linked to Babylon. Yes.
And the third second angel's message is
come out. Come out of her.
The
And that brings
I'm sorry, but I just want to take you
guys back just to this one place.
Can Because the third angel's message
says, "Don't take the mark of the
beast."
Why will a Muslim
What will be the
How will that affect him? The Muslim
doesn't really have a rest day. That's
what the Bible says.
>> Friday is just a lunchtime prayer.
>> Yeah. There's no rest day. And humanity
needs a rest day. And the Muslim world,
in conjunction with the Western world,
has already accepted Sunday as a rest
day also in terms of commerce and
banking. Perfect. So, there is no reason
why he shouldn't accept the mark of the
beast and accept the authority of
Catholicism. He's already gone into a
triune union with him in the Abrahamic
accord.
>> Which is run by the Catholic Church.
>> And you can go and look at the buildings
that have been erected for the Abrahamic
accord. They're not based on
Protestantism, the the Christian one.
It's based on Catholicism. The whole
architecture, everything associated with
it is based on Catholicism. It's not
biblical. Thank you. Because it's just I
hear that question every time coming and
I just want people to know that that's
not the stumbling block that's going to
keep them from implementing the mark of
the beast.
And because we're dealing with the with
a very difficult situation of reaching
the people that are in that window,
God is actually intervening through
prayer.
I mean, through through visions and
through dreams that people are having
for them personally. Isn't that also a
fulfillment of the prophecy of Joel?
That the young people and the men and
the women will have dreams and God will
will lead because God is in the business
of saving souls,
not in condemning souls.
He didn't come to condemn. He came to
save. He's a God of love. He's a God of
of equality.
And the Islamic world needs to be freed
from the shackles of of their theology
as much as the Roman Catholic needs to
be freed or the occultist or the Hindu
or the Buddhist or the shaman or
whatever you want to call them.
>> The Jew.
All of them.
The Jew has recognized that the time of
Daniel chapter uh nine
has passed
because of their unbelief. No. Then come
back to believe and accept that the
Messiah that was prefigured in their
sacrificial system is their Messiah.
Don't accept a spurious Messiah that
will come and wipe out your enemies so
that you can rule. We are all of one
blood. We are all children of God and
Ishmael is a son of Abraham. But Abraham
goes all the way back to being a son of
God because he was created by God
through Adam. Amen. And also in that in
the covenant that Paul mentions in
Galatians, the two covenants, the
covenant one from Mount Sinai, Hagar,
because he says Abraham had two sons. Uh
and then he says talks about Isaac and
talks about Ishmael and says and then
and then talks about Jerusalem above and
then Jerus- and then talks about Mount
Sinai. One gendereth to bondage. The
other one is freedom. One persecutes the
other one. And the one that gendereth to
bondage persecutes the one that's free.
So so for those that claim that Paul
taught that that that
that Islam is is is the religion that
came from God, then then Paul here
clearly says he makes a distinction
between
and he calls one Hagar one
and and Ishmael and the other one is
Isaac and Jerusalem above, our mother
Jerusalem above. So the these
the freedom that Muslims will feel
will only come to them when they find
Christ like I did and like many millions
of other Muslims that have come become
Christians and believers who finally the
shackles fell off. They were freed. They
came forward and they're now standing in
freedom in Jesus Christ. And my might
add that that when Jesus revealed to me
the Sabbath, the night that he showed me
the Sabbath, it was in a dream. And in
my dream
a Seventh-day Adventist Bible colporteur
had already told me about the Sabbath
and I didn't know if it was true or not.
So I prayed and I asked Jesus. I said,
"Lord, show me if this is really true,
if this is your Sabbath." And that night
he gave me that dream and in my dream he
showed me the Sabbath and he it stood
out. And I was [clears throat] actually
standing next to a Seventh-day Adventist
church and it was Sabbath. It was
Saturday. But the day was alive. There
was this active electricity that was
vibing in the air, something that only
with spiritual eyes you can see. And in
my dream that spiritual eye was given to
me. And then God showed me the Bible.
And next to it he showed me the writings
of what we call the spirit of prophecy.
And I had no idea that there was even a
spirit prophecy at that moment. All of
that was shown to me in my dream. And in
my dream a basement was shown to me in a
church.
And that basement later on I was
baptized in that church and I went into
that basement where they had fellowship.
They would have their Sabbath Saturday
on Sabbath they would have potluck in
that basement. I stood in that same
basement that I had seen in my dream.
I'd never been in that
basement before. All of that was
revealed to me in my dream. And and the
writings of spirit prophecy, writings of
Ellen G. White was revealed to me, shown
to me in my dream. All of that. So this
this God is working. Yes, as as he
mentioned the book of Joel, this is
happening in a large sense. Why is it
happening in a large sense to Muslims?
Part of the reason is is that God told
Abraham, "For your sake, I will bless
your son Ishmael." It was never in God's
plan for him to have a son named
Ishmael, but
husband and wife took it upon themselves
to go and be gods for a moment and they
did they they believed Lucifer. They
were standing at the tree. They can be
like God. So they decided, "Let's make a
child so we can fulfill God's promise."
So they made a child with him
taking Hagar and now God says, "Okay,
you put you put yourself and you put me
in a special predicament just like Peter
put Christ in a predicament and had
boasted that Jesus will pay tax."
And Jesus said, "You should have not
said that, but now because you've said
it, go. There's going to be a fish and
there's going to be money in its mouth.
You take that money and you pay your tax
and my tax."
Abraham and and and Sarah did the same
thing. They put God in a predicament. So
now God says, "Okay, Abraham, because of
you,
I will bless your son Ishmael.
I will bless him.
But he is not the chosen blessing. That
blessing will come through Isaac. And
because of that promise, God is working
very diligently and hard to reach
Muslims with the gospel of Jesus Christ.
And it's and it's paying off. Praise
God. Paying off all over the place. I
agree with you 100%. What what they need
to understand regarding the Sabbath,
the Sabbath is resting in a completed
work
that God did and not we did.
Pagan religion, all false religion, is
based on what we can accomplish.
And Hagar is Abraham's effort to fulfill
God's promise.
>> Mhm.
Whereas Sarah is God's promise that even
the barren will be able to bring forth
life.
And that is salvation by faith compared
with salvation through your own efforts.
That's why the religion of Catholicism
is one of rituals and sacraments,
sacramental activities, and pilgrimages,
and indulgences, and Islam is exactly
the same. A religion of ritual and works
and beads and pilgrimages and
own effort.
And God is looking to see who comes up
and steps up to the plate. And the
ultimate sacrifice is if you give your
life for the cause of Allah, you go
straight to heaven.
And that's why you have a religion like
that and
it is not the religion of the Bible.
It is not the same deity and anybody who
teaches it, I believe is either
sincerely deceived or deceptive.
So I just want to before we close off
completely, Shahbaz, will you just tell
the viewers about your ministry that you
are doing?
Yes. Um
Well, our ministry the ministry is
Advent Lighthouse Ministries and
your viewers can
check us out on on our website
adventlighthouse.org.
And our ministry
basically geared and tailored to reach
Muslims specifically
Persian speaking Muslims. There's about
130 million Iranian Persian speaking
people in the world. And um uh
it's not
it's not just
that but beyond that but that's our
specific goal and and point. And God
raised this ministry and and we are
reaching people in a in an unprecedented
way now. We have
20 Bible workers that we support that
live on the ground in these in that
region and they are planting churches
and
and this year we're going to
bring on another
probably about 25 more Bible workers
that will
that will add to our number. So, we
should have around by the end of 2026
um we should have about 45
Bible workers that that that work for
our ministry. And God has blessed God is
the one who's making this happen. We're
just following his directions. The Lord
has blessed me. We we have
good people here that that support the
ministry that work at the ministry and
and and our website and our Instagram
account is is is growing amongst the
Persian speaking people diaspora outside
of the region in the 10 40 window region
and within the 10 40 window region. And
people are hearing the gospel. They're
hearing the messages. In fact in fact in
fact the husband of one of our employees
who's an Iranian he's translating
Walter's
presentations into Persian. So, Walter
is now speaking in tongues in Persian
and
and it's really fascinating to see him
to see those sermons in Persian. So, God
is blessing this ministry. Our work is
growing and please pray for us and
and we'll continue to pray for you. God
bless you. Thank you. It was a an honor
to speak to you. It was an absolute
pleasure to speak to you. I know this
will be considered controversial by many
but I believe it is a sincere longing
to reach people that have been kept in
in basically darkness regarding all of
these issues.
And
everybody has a right
to hear the gospel and to be able to
respond to it and
and your mission is very very important
and God will bless your mission because
it is the the message for our time to
those people that you are trying to
reach. May God richly bless you what you
are doing.
Thank you. Thank you so much. Thank you
for having me. God bless you. Thank you.
>> Shall we close in prayer?
Our loving heavenly Father
we look at
the the other son
and we look at the turmoil of history
and the blood that has been shed over
the ages
and basically what we have is a war
against the son of God.
And Lord I pray
that even
this presentation will somehow be
instrumental in reaching people so that
they can make a decision for the times
that we are living in.
I pray that you will bless the ministry
of Shahbaz
and that you will bless the efforts that
we put forth to bring the three angels
messages to the world.
And thank you Lord that we can have
discussions like this
and may they do the work
that we envision for it to do. It's our
prayer in Jesus' name. Amen. Amen.
Amen.
>> [music]
[music]